Before we jump into intra-domain routing, let's take a
look at what a topology might look like inside
a single autonomous system. A topology inside an AS
consists of nodes and edges that connect them. The nodes
are sometimes called points of presence, or PoPs. A
PoP is typically located in a dense population center,
so that it can be close to the PoPs
of other providers for easier interconnection. And, also close to
other customers for cheaper backhaul to
customers that may be pruchasing connectivity from
this particular AS. The edges between
pops are typically constrained by the location
of fiber paths. Which for the
sake of convenience. Typically parallel major transportation
routes such as railroads and highways. Here's an example of a single AS topology
which is the Abilene Network, which is a research
network in the United States. Each of these locations
would be considered a Pop, and each of these
PoPs may have one or more edges between them.
Georgia Tech is an autonomous system that connects at
the Atlanta PoP of the Abilene Network. Here's a
close up of the Abilene Network in the south
eastern U.S.. The Abilene network connects to other universities
in the southeast near Atalanta and an internet exchange
point called SOX or southern crossroads. Now thus far
we've just talked about the topology of an autonomous
system which essentially defines the graph. The next step
is to compute paths over that topology. A process
called routing. Routing is the process by which nodes
discover where to forward traffic so that it reaches
a certain node. There are two types of intra-domain routing.
One is called distance vector, and the other is called link
state. In the rest of this lesson we'll explore the two
different types of intra-domain routing and the advantages and disadvantages of
each of them. Let's first take a look at distance vector routing.